piscine naturelle de la maladie vous
posez une question n'auraient pas écouté
vous on développe aujourd'hui pénurie
nous tous et cette question c'est pour
ça que je me fiche un peu de ce que les
gens pensent de moi si
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonjour quelle
était la vidéo d' analyse la plus
demandée depuis le début 2020 depuis fin
février d'après vous comme ça au hasard
au hasard par là c'est évidemment
l'analyse non verbale du professeur
grave donc c'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui on va faire une analyse non
verbale verbal parra verbal tous les
verbes
si c'est la première fois que vous
regardez d'une de mes vidéos et encore
plus une vidéo analyse je m'appelle
fabian l'uqar et petit disclaimer que
vous pouvez regarder ou pas c'est si
vous avez déjà vu des vidéos dans ces
vidéos analyse je donne pas un avis sur
la personne ou sur le sujet en question
en fait je vais aller piocher dans
pleins beatty de rhétorique de non
verbal de par hasard balles dont
certains outils qui sont considérés par
certains comme étant des pseudosciences
ce que je vais dire ça va pas être une
vérité ça va être ma vérité à moi mon
analyse subjective en utilisant tous ces
outils là et en essayant de faire au
mieux mais ce n'est pas une vérité
absolue à la fin ce n'est que la vérité
de moi à ce moment là et j'essaie de ne
pas prendre parti sur les débats en
cours de sujets que j'analyse donc voila
en gros je ne suis ni contreras août me
proud quand je fais ce genre d'exercice
je vais essayer d'être le plus objectif
possible mais c'est subjectif pour les
raisons que vous avez compris c'était
pas clair c'est parti pour llanelli
on va commencer avec une récente c'est
celle du professeur didier raoult qui
était invité à bfm le 3 juin ou quelque
chose comme ça en tout cas la vidéo a
été close le 3 juin par bfm moi que
contre moi ça m'a pas rendu service que
trump est mort il ya d'un coup tous les
anti trop de pistes qui sont trouvé des
antilles chloroquine parce que je ne
sais pas quoi ils font des assimilations
étrange si vous voulez mais je peux vous
dire je regardais tout à l'heure le
nombre de pays dans lequel hydroxy
chloroquine est recommandé aux etats
unis c'est par là il ya quelque chose
que j'ai remarquée chez didier raoul tu
en tout cas dans les vidéos récentes
comme celle ci c'est qu'il a deux
positionnements quand il parle soit il
répond à la personne en regardant dans
les yeux avec assez peu de gestes il est
toujours relativement fermé est assez
stable en fait dans ce qu'il fait et
après le moment où il a le regard qui se
perd un petit peu dans le vague
avec la petite barbichette et ça ce sont
les moments analytique chez lui c'est à
dire on voit qu'il est en train de
piocher plein de données dans sa tête
pour construire une logique et une
cohérence est ce que je peux dire déjà
c'est que encore une fois on va pas
traiter du fond de ce qui parle de la
forme c'est qu'au moment où il
déversent des affirmations il est
toujours sûr d'avoir une construction
mentale établi qui est précédé de
données donc on a affaire à quelqu'un
qui réfléchit alors peut-être après il
réfléchit mal ou pas avec les bonnes
odeurs mais en tout cas dans ces moments
là il ya vraiment ça on le reverra mille
fois je pense dans la vidéo pour
commander ça concerne 4 5 milliards de
personnes sur 7 milliards nantais donc
quand on en fait une histoire parisiano
marseillais je pense qu'on est cinglé
donc si vous voulez il ya des ja 4,5
milliards de gens qui vivent dans des
pays dans lequel l'appuyer roxy
chloroquine est recommandée en
prévention et traitement ou en
thérapeutique à souchez ou non avec la
citroën ici donc il faut arrêter de
personnes vraiment en arrière parce que
là il était en train de donner de la
donnée brute
donc il est toujours concentré quand il
fait ça on le voit c'est pas de la
colère c'est de la concentration et
après il a une réaction qui est
intéressante des à 4,5 milliards de gens
qui vivent dans des pays dans lequel la
cuillère roxy clos qu il est recommandé
en prévention et traitement en temps ou
en thérapeutique à souchez ou non avec
le citron donc là on n'était pas sûrs du
mépris mais on est sur un injuste léger
agacement de quelque chose qui n'a pas
de sens pour lui puisque la journaliste
rajoute avec votre traitement et on voit
il perd toute la concentration
il a un changement de position de tête
il balaye ça en fait c est juste au
niveau des sorties on a un début
d'exécution mais il se reprend iard de
gens qui vivent dans des pays dans
lequel l'impression d'appuyer roxy
chloroquine est recommandée en
prévention et traitement en temps ou en
thérapeutique association d'alexis
changement de position aurait été
analysés donc le fait et je maintiens ça
et on voit bien c'est avec cette
histoire claudine des gens qui sont
censés être intelligent d'un coup des
raisons des réactions passionnelles sur
la chloroquine à propos de trump et je
pense que c'est les réactions
d'imbéciles cette vidéo elle est
intéressant parce que je l'avais regardé
un mois en direct
il est très stable en fait on n'a pas
vraiment de micro expressions
particulier on a pas de changement
émotionnel particulier il est assez posé
assez réfléchi assez stable on a tous
les signes de l'honnêteté c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas
encore une fois je sais pas s'il se
trompe ou pas mais lui quand il dit des
choses il n'est pas dans un espèce de
manipulation de contre vérités ou quoi
on été repeints qui suit un schéma de
pensée ou lui pense être dans le vrai
quand il le dit quoi c'est mon métier
vous pouvez pas me l'aurait comme ça que
le gens du land cette soif et l'aurait
part des choses aussi fantasque que
c'est inimaginable quelles conséquences
alors de cette décision précipitée ou
trop rapide pour les patients notamment
les patients forte heureusement ici on
n'a plus alors donc de toute manière ça
c'est quoi on n'a pas un petit peu de un
petit peu de satisfaction là en même
temps un peu un petit peu des rois ni je
crois on est on est on est sûr allégé
mépris je sais pas si c'est de l'ironie
ou allégées mépris parce qu'on n'a que
cette partie là de la lèvre qui s'ouvre
en fait quand il dit nous ici on en a
plus donc à ce qu'ils méprisent la
question est-ce qu'il veut ironisé
dessus n'est ce pas sa manière naturelle
de parler je pense qu'il ya un espèce de
pied de nez derrière une expression qui
existent peut-être margaux pinot leurs
aptitudes donc du 27 mars sur 80
patients et la question c'était de
savoir si c'était de la recherche ou du
soin parce que si c'était de la
recherche en essais y avait des règles à
respecter et la question c'est de savoir
est-ce que vous en êtes affronte pas du
tout on encore une fois une des folies
qui a pris ce pays dans cette situation
qu'il ya des raisons très peu comparé
aux marques et sa gaieté déjà tout à
l'heure à chaque fois qu'on pose une
question qui en tout cas l'embêtent dans
sa sensibilité où il dit je ne peux pas
répondre à ça il faut que je construise
ma réponse à chaque fois il a un micro
arrêt mais on entend clairement un
déglutit cement juste là pas du tout on
encore une fois une et à plein des
folies caprice pays dont et juste après
de la déglutition
là il commence à dérouler en fait je me
pensais plus soirée de l'argent mais
parce que vous aviez une super record de
3500 passion j'en ai pu faire un groupe
en pétrole
comme ça on aurait aimé le savoir
l'évolution naturelle de la maladie mais
taisez vous poser une question en
rapport
écoutez moi ça c'est assez alors ça ce
passage il est quand même office team
ce qui est intéressant c'est que a
priori j'ai vu aucun signe de colère
quand quand il lui a dit taisez vous
donc on est sur un affront un affront
protocolaire parce que il est induit que
quand un journaliste parle on se tait et
on l'écouté que voilà parfois c'est pas
induit que quand on parle le journaliste
ne coupe pas mais ça c'est le protocole
journalistique on a l'habitude de ça et
lui comme il veut répondre avant
qu'elles mettent trop d'éléments dans sa
question qu'elle soit trop une question
à rallonge au lieu de s'énerver comme on
pourrait le penser que je crois qu'ils
avaient pas d'énervement il continue à
être français comme il l'était
précédemment on sait que c'est de la
réflexion il baisse la tête
un mode jeu peu plus réfléchir bon la
maille mise en avant mais c'est pas
demain de stop
c'est la seule main d'ailleurs inquiets
qui fait bouger depuis tout à l'heure
parce qu'il est un truc très stable pas
les narines sont pas dilater vous
propose à peut-être un peu de colère ok
mais c'est plus de l'agacement que de la
colère c'est un peu retroussé ici mais
en même temps on n'a pas les yeux qui
sont écartés il n'est pas en train de la
regarder directement dans le regard qui
serait vraiment le symbole d'une colère
forte
on n'a pas encore ça c'est plus du tuc
ultime casse un peu la tête et le
journaliste prend sa défense
et là il relève le menton c'est à dire
qui se met dans la position de attention
attention à ne pas manquer de respect
donc le journaliste se dit il en train
de manquer de respect à ma collègue et
lui relève la tête là on est sur du
combat de coqs en deux secondes quoi
coûter moins et du coup ils
l'abandonnent en disant écoutez moi il
pose le truc il a continué sa mécanique
il n'a pas arrêté son fil de pensée et
du coup la journaliste en sortant juste
en rigolant un peu pour virer le malaise
je crois c'est quand même un combat
incroyable parce que il vient d'y avoir
un vrai combat des goûts dans cette
interview est en fait il n'a jamais
arrêté le fil de sa pensée pour pouvoir
leur prendre là et il a gagné puisqu'il
l'afp les terres en fête au final je
leur mette c'était un peu fou à voir
ferracci taisez vous me posez une
question dans le rapport écoutez moi je
vous le dis moi oui
dans cette situation - mon devoir et moi
c'est de soigner les gens t'aiment donne
envie de voir un autre passage qu'elle
parle et qu'il était un peu de stars etc
je vais retrouver ça au bout d'un moment
vous savez que bape est pas pareil mais
que vous sachiez pas comment je me
paraissait très mal et de la médecine de
la recherche
paris nice est à dire qu en tout cas
quelles que soient les éléments que vous
preniez vous ne trouverez jamais en
dehors des dix premiers quelles que
soient les éléments vous voyez quels que
soient les marqueurs que vous prenez si
on regarde cette expression elle est
hyper intéressante on n'est pas
quelqu'un qui dans lego à ce moment là
on n'est pas quelqu'un qui est dans
l'excitation à quelqu'un qui qui est
même en train de réfléchir à la
puissance de ce qui va dire si c'est bon
ou pas en fait avant de revoir le
passage là je croyais c'est un moment
plus arrogant mais y'a pas d'arrogance
du tout et on le voit j'ai pas même pas
besoin de vous le détailler on le voit
sur le visage puis après ce que du doute
c'est un mouvement d'épaulé ou pas et de
la médecine de la recherche
oui il ya un mouvement des pôles la
vraie mouvements légers spontanée donc à
contrôler pour le coup tu es oui je sais
pas encore à temps je réfléchis que vous
sachiez pas comment je peux parler de la
casa de la recherche juste là oui c'est
à dire qu en tout cas quel que soit les
les éléments que vous preniez des
déconnexions des cons détail le visage
n'y a pas de bruit toute arrogance latif
faire que le font par et arrogant mais
dans la forme on la retrouve pas
forcément on va faire un rapide retour
dans le temps on va remonter huit ans en
arrière en 2012 parce que ce que je
viens de voir je veux dire on va pas
détaillé la vidéo tout le monde parce
qu'il n'a pas de changement significatif
et on a plein d'autres vidéos à regarder
mais surtout celle ci elle est
intéressant de dire huit ans avant
comment est-ce qu'on porte en verbale et
non verbale en plus il n'a pas cette
fameuse petite barbe et ses cheveux
aussi longs qui qui font que bon il a
pris des toques en fait un physique par
rapport à ça on va pouvoir regarder ça
donc ça c'était en 2012 sur un colloque
sur les maladies infectieuses émergentes
donc quand un sujet de santé est pris je
m'excuse vous dire ça mais c'est la
vérité
non mais si
on le sait on le sait bien quand un
sujet de santé est pris est pris en
otage par les politiques pour le gérer
c'est une catastrophe il vaut mieux nous
laisser faire ça parce que les gens ont
plus confiance en nous donc ça c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
et c'est à dire que regarder l'auto
acquiesce monclar manens de sa tête le
catastrophe il vaut mieux nous laisser
cela parce que les gens plus conflit
oui oui pourtant cette confiance là à
dire qu'il s'auto acquiesce en
permanence ça on est sûr quelqu'un
persuader de ce qu'il dit déjà là je
sais pas trop de quoi il parle mais il
en est sûr il faut s'en méfier parce que
c'est quoi ces petits regards à côté je
ne sais pas qui est cet homme qu'on a il
est
les musées mis dans le mépris j'ai
l'impression sur sur le côté droit
une des tâches les regards on a un
risque
ouais ok on n'est pas serein convaincu
de didier insulte à ce moment-là à ton
d'oubli qui sont infectieux à peu près
25 % au moins des cancers sont d'origine
infectieuse et puis les infections
émergentes qui naissent de trois aspects
d'une part des outils nouveaux qui
compte notre ignorance une partie de
notre ignorance est à peu près 90% 80 à
90% de ce qu'on voit là parce que moi
j'essaye vraiment de faire le comparatif
avec ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui de ce
professeur déjà huit ans avant il a la
même manière de réfléchir de se
comporter
il a le même parrain verbale avec ses
intonations etc
il a le même verbale dans ses
constructions et les mots choisis
utilisé et il a le même non verbale avec
plutôt un seul bras qui bouge est plutôt
juste le regard en réflexion sans
forcément colère ou animosité donc huit
ans avant il se comportait comme
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'il ya une
rupture à un moment donné de sa manière
de se percevoir lui même ou de percevoir
son travail ou ce qu'il dit puisque là
il était venu en qualité d'orateur
corolle pour un colloque nous on s'est
beaucoup battu labeur on essaie d'en
prendre une proportion non négligeable
et je vous dirais pas ça ce mec est une
blague en mode il a fait une croix sur
ce qu'il
dit il en a aucun intérêt c'est terrible
il ya un jugement à mépris le menton
aulas les supérieurs qu'ils remontent
tu sais pas qui est ce qu a dit toi dans
les commentaires juste on confirme ce
que je pressentais que toutes ces
attitudes et sa manière de fonctionner
étaient déjà présentes il ya huit ans ça
m'intéressait de voir ça les comités je
m'excuse de dire ça vous voyez vous ne
faites revenir à paris pour parler cinq
minutes mais dans le fait perdre plus
d'une journée pour ça donc je le ferai
une fois je vais pas faire que ça parce
que je dois travailler tentant donc les
comités sont surtout composées doazit
food parisien
parfois les deux pour des raisons
mécaniques je m'excuse ce pays pourrait
aussi un peu se moderniser et commencé à
faire des vidéoconférences qui nous
oblige pas à perdre une journée pour
vous lire discuter avec pendant une demi
heure là là pour le coup là on l'a on
voit les signes de colère on les voit en
fait j'apprends à le connaître ayew on
voit dans les mouvements bref des pôles
c'est pas des choses qu'il a l'habitude
d'avoir
et au delà de ses intonations il est
encore plus français que d'habitude et
on a vraiment des ruptures de mouvements
des pôles et quand il fait ses gestes
d'habitude ses gestes il s'arrête au
niveau du visage
là ça peut monter jusqu en haut de la
tête pendant une heure de vol il faut un
peu se moderniser on ne peut pas se
passer dans une salle de réunion au
ministère
donc ça aux états unis on faire
activement au dessus de la pièce plus
des polonais la pologne qui avec un ordi
de faire une visioconférence il faut
s'arrêter nous fait revenir les
institutions des lobbyings majeur qui
souvent n'a rien à voir avec leur
finalité encore au dessus de la tête on
entend aussi un danseur verbale dans la
donation et en corse est encore monté au
dessus de la tête
ok parce que c'est intéressant on
commence à avoir des clés sur sa manière
de fonctionner donc on va pouvoir
regarder d'autres vidéos peut-être qu'on
lui parle de la chloroquine pour voir
comment il réagit donc voilà olivier
dahan il vous avez je je je je ne
commente pas non plus jamais ce que
disent les gens je le demande parce que
je veux pas être désagréable plus il a
l'âge d'être mon fils donc j'ai beaucoup
d'indulgence pour lui si vous voulez on
est sur une petite attaque à dominer mme
de 10 ha
il a l'âge d'être mon fils ça c'est
superflu par exemple dans donc pour
quelqu'un qui utilisent de telles axiome
pour construire une pensée réfléchie
avec
des causes à effets etc c'est dommage de
faire une petite attaque un petit pic à
dominer même sur l'âge de la personne du
contradicteur parce que ça dessert son
propos dans ce cas il faut attendre la
fin de la pièce la fin du combat on
verra bien mais si vous regardez le
nombre de morts qu'a eus en chine
vous avez entendu est-ce que vous avez
juste entendu il faut attendre la fin de
la pièce la fin du combat on verra bien
mais si vous restez la petite pause avec
lui qui déglutit avant d'enchaîner
vraiment son propos et sa réflexion
comme comme on a eu tout à l'heure sur
des faits pénurie de tests au moment où
on aurait pu essayer de faire la
politique qu'on développe aujourd'hui
pénurie de tous et cette question c'est
pour ça que je me fiche un peu de ce que
les gens pensent de moi si j'avais
attiré l'attention sur ce que je pensais
être la préparation du pays là c'est
assez marrant quand il dit je m'en fiche
c'est un je m'en fiche un peu de ce que
les gens pensent de moi au niveau de la
tentation mais on est sur une intonation
de vérité par contre on a le regard qui
paraît la main qui se met juste là
devant la bouche comme si c'est quelque
chose qu'il n'aurait peut-être pas dû
sortir comme ça ou qui est pas si penser
que ça je ne peux pas conclusion du
pourquoi tout ce que je sais c'est que
d'habitude quand il la scène une vérité
il n'a pas ce comportement là avec les
yeux fuyants et la main devant la bouche
c'est pourquoi vous vous n'avez pas
mener une telle étude avec un groupe
témoin non mais paye avec un placebo
et puis avec un groupe que vous traitez
avec vous raconter vraiment parce que
moi comme écoutez je vais vous dire
encore une fois vous pouvez pas
comprendre ce que je vous dis je le
verrai c'est de vous le dire mais à
travers moi c'est aux gens que vous vous
adressez non l'équipe se demande
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait cette
étude randomisée regarder à
c'est marrant à sa sas et c'est vraiment
le visage que vous connaissez sur un
enfant qui fait non non ça je sais j'en
veux pas non je suis pas d'accord avec
ça c'est en fait ils assez naïf dans
cette passion non verbale non mais vois
jouer je suis voilée garantie que poser
des questions
entre vérin et moi pour voir qu'il croit
ce que allah on a quand même des
l'autosatisfaction - pour quelqu'un qui
s'en fiche de ce que les gens pensent de
lui
et puis c'est très défiant avec la
relever comme ça lasse et fixe la liste
pas de ceux ci ce que c'est que la
crédibilité à marseille je suis certain
que vous avez un record en france fait
fait les gens se posent la question fait
les sondages au regard des projets mais
est ce que c'est une raison pour clore
le nez avec le jeune et j'ai vu fait les
sondages au regard des projets très
suffisance on va donner que ça je les ai
vus moi je pense qu'on peut s'arrêter là
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
encore une semaine ne traitons pas le
fond dans cette vidéo d' analyse on
essayé de traiter la forme c'est à dire
le para verbal un peu de verbale et du
non verbal pour voir si lui disent
qu'ils pensent et ce qu'ils en colère
est ce qu'il est dans la manipulation
est ce qu'il est dans l'image est ce
qu'il est dans lego moi ce que je peux
en dire c'est que j'ai pas vu quelqu'un
qui était dans lego j'ai pas vu
quelqu'un qui était dans l'image et pas
forcément vu quelqu'un en colère non
plus ceux plus quelqu'un qui veut faire
son truc dans son coin et en tout cas
qui croient en tout ce qui dit donc
vraiment j'insiste dessus je ne suis pas
pro ou anti je n'ai aucune compétence en
fait pour pouvoir préjuger de sa part
contre on est sur quelqu'un de sincère
de sincère dans ce qu'il dit et de
beaucoup plus nuancée que ce que je
croyais avant d'avoir analysé ces vidéos
ça c'est quand la partie verbale c'est
beaucoup plus nuancé dans plein
d'endroits où j'ai vu des phrases
ressortir épopée des fois dans dans des
interviews ou d'un thé résumé d'à côté
on en apprend beaucoup d'à côté assez
peu parce qu'on n'a pas quelqu'un qui
essaye de cacher des choses donc bye
quand il n'y a rien à cacher juste on
voit ça mais je suis content d'avoir
fait cette analyse ne serait ce que pour
moi pour en savoir un peu plus et
peut-être aussi quand même en profiter
pour placer le fait que moelleux
cornaz virus et le confinement
s'arracher le coeur ni ma tournée qui
s'arrêtait la tournée à l'euro prend en
octobre et j'ai la dernière date
parisienne donc le zénith de paris le 20
novembre 2020 qui ne donne vraiment
spéciale de mon spectacle de mentalisme
d'humour qui est un afflux qui va avoir
lieu a priori tout va bien s'il faut
leur porte et on ne reportera évidemment
mais il reste déjà plus de la moitié des
places donc si vous voulez venir
je vous invite à cliquer le lien dans la
description là c'est la salle telles
qu'aller au moment où on tourne la vidéo
vous voyez tous les sièges noirs
télésiège prix donc n'hésitez pas à
réserver sa au plus vite et j'ai hâte de
vous retrouver sur les planches
j'espère que cette analyse vous aura plu
particulièrement aussi n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce en l'air abonnez vous à
cette chaîne c'est gratuit je m'appelle
fabien olicard est comme ça vous verrez
les prochaines analyses arrivée vous
n'allez pas les rater parce que vous
avez sûrement déjà raté si vous n'êtes
pas abonné et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt
ciao